what did you learn about death
about life from
losing her
I feel like the facade of the material
world
was made evident to me at a very young
age you know most children grow up
and
their parents want to protect them from
everything and and I felt that too you
know my my mother wanted to downplay her
own tragedy so that me and my brother
could live a fruitful and fulfilling
life my father wanted to protect us
from
the hardship of her life so that we
could live fulfilling lives he was he'd
often be the only father on a field trip
even though he was a distinguished
Professor I mean he was a busy man
he he was a very busy man but he tried
to show up at a field trip and tried to
make our lives as normal as possible
but
in the process we always understood that
there was more to life than what other
children were seeing it as and now I
know that as an adult there's more to
life than what other adults see it as
the material world
uh disappointed early on so that we
could see beyond it and I often tell
people that you know
there are many that grow up in tragedy
orphan children
um refugees
that
grow up and do incredible things because
they immediately see past
the
facade they see through all of the
material Promises of this world the
deception of it
and that you can choose to be bitter as
a result of that or you can choose to
be better
and I think that for me I had to
consciously make that decision that I
was going to live a life
of prayer I was going to live a life of
Charity I was going to live a life of
commitment
and
in that process
invest in something that's greater
invest in something that doesn't
disappoint
and so I believe in God I believe in the
hereafter
and I believe that God will not let any
trial
or effort in this life go to waste
without it being repaid in the Hereafter
and so I work towards that and so life
and death
I understood existence to be
Transcendent early on
that if I believe that there was nothing
to life except for life I would be a
very bitter person but because
I know that there is more to it than
this
I'm able to uh exist in it
without being depressed by it
existence is Transcendence
what happens after we die
after
the
material instantiation
uh Fades away
so the Quran tells us
that God brought us from the darkness of
the womb
into this life
you were nothing but a dirty drop of
fluid and you became this fully
proportioned human being from the
darkness of the womb you come into this
life
you experience it and then you go to the
darkness of the Grave only to be
resurrected once again
and that we are
Souls
with bodies not bodies with souls and
there's a huge difference between those
two things
this is the vehicle that contains us
here
this is the material world that we
encounter here
but we are not this
and this is not our entire existence and
so the soul continues this is a life in
which
we
seek to worship Him
and seek to live in accordance with the
purpose that he has set out for us
and after we pass away our soul
continues onwards
either to reward or to punishment or to
a mixture of both but it's a it's a
realm of accountability
and
hopefully it's a realm of reward should
we exist in a way that he wants us to
exist